[Music]
splatoon too is a colorful
family-friendly shooter but there's
something sinister hidden under all that
ink if you found some of the sunken
Scrolls in the first game you might know
what I'm talking about I will be
spoiling some of the scrolls from the
second game so if you'd rather find them
yourself come back later but don't worry
we have plenty spoiler free splatoon
videos coming your way so make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss those
splatoon is bright silly a little weird
and post-apocalyptic yes I know that
sounds crazy but according to the sunken
Scrolls from the first game humans have
been extinct for roughly 12,000 years
due to rising sea levels I'm not sure
where kevin costner story from
Waterworld fits into this timeline but
I'm sure it's there somewhere never
expected anything with it juiceless as
more and more land was swallowed up by
water the human population started to
dwindle those who remained were
desperate to find dry land but our
species couldn't adapt quickly enough
and ultimately drown beneath the rising
tides as tragic as this is this left
room for the inkling ancestors to take
the remaining land thousands of years
later squids evolved to sprout legs arms
and an impeccable fashion sense inkling
art literature and science flourished
inkling archaeologists even uncovered
human fossils that'll be me if super
smash bros doesn't come to the switch
though the inkling species may seem
prosperous they work without their
conflicts as it became harder and harder
to find land the octarians an
intelligent race of octopus-like
creatures waged war against the Inklings
the octarians crush the Inklings in the
early battles of the great war scroll 12
from the original splatoon attributes
the inkling loss to being unable to wake
up early enough in the morning to defend
themselves that I can relate to
although there was a time when Inklings
and octarians were friendly with each
other the bitter rivalry between the
species has been going on for a long
time after trading victories and losses
for years the octarians were pushed
underground some Scrolls you find
throughout the first game showcased
propaganda from both sides of the war
this one in particular looks to be
created by the octarians as it describes
Inklings as simple and predatory
meanwhile Inklings accused the octarians
of being highly aggressive in another
scroll splatoon 2 doesn't provide much
more backstory on the inkling of teryan
war than the first game but it does
flesh out the newly emerged salmon
species if you've been following
splatoon too then you probably know
about salmon run a wave based
cooperative mode that pits your team
against humanoid Salmons armed with pots
and pans deadly to pots and pans might I
add a prophecy from the lore states that
when the smoke rises from the seven
rings the pink fish will emerge from the
sea devouring all the creatures of the
land this could mean that the octarians
and Inklings need to team up to fight
off the pink fish but will have to wait
for splatoon three to see if that
actually happens
the tune too may not be a story heavy
gain but what's there is fascinating and
there's plenty more to dig into for
those interested if you have any other
tidbits about the Lord that I may have
missed feel free to drop them in the
comments thank you so much for watching
and if you enjoyed this video maybe give
it a like it really helps us out